hey everyone it's Warren and now that
Captain Marvel is out and we have that
new Avengers and game footage we have
some things to talk about we have a lot
of new info with Captain Marvel coming
out a lot of tie ins to Avengers in game
especially with the new footage that we
have for in-game I must issue a spoiler
alert for Captain Marvel if you have not
seen the movie and you do not want
anything spoiled here's your warning
also a lot of you have asked me what I
thought about the movie well I recently
sat down and did a live video where I
talked about it for about an hour with
my buddy Supes I'll be sure to link that
video up above and I'll put it in the
description as well so be sure to head
over and check it out and subscribe to
Supes if you'd like more superhero
related content okay so the Captain
Marvel post-credit scene of course was
footage from Avengers endgame the
Avengers somehow have Nick Fury's pager
and they're trying to figure out what it
is and who it's calling and then of
course Captain Marvel pops up and says
where's fury and thanks to the internet
we now have this awesome new picture of
her in that scene and with that we get a
look at the new uniform that she'll be
wearing an Avengers end game and as you
can see it is different the traditional
Captain Marvel uniform that we saw her
wear at the end of the film was just her
crew uniform with a color change and
that uniform for the most part was very
comic accurate and now her uniform has a
lot more gold to it as you can see on
her shoulders so at the end of Captain
Marvel we know that Carol Danvers is
going to other galaxies we know this
because when she gave Nick Fury the
pager back she said it should be able to
reach a few galaxies away and then at
the end of the movie we saw her leave
the galaxy with the scroll and not to
mention Captain Marvel took place in
1995 over 20 years has passed between
the events of Captain Marvel and
Avengers endgame so this suit could be
something completely different than what
she wore during the Captain Marvel movie
which was her crew uniform we know that
she's been defending other planets and
other galaxies while she's been away
from Earth so who knows when or where
she got this other uniform but it's
clear that it's different they most
likely did this change to go along with
the Captain Marvel that we're going to
see in Avengers in-game because she's
going to be a little different again
over 20 years has passed that's 20 years
that she's had to grow to learn to tap
into her full powers so she won't
exactly be the same captain
marvel that we saw because she's going
to have grown a lot which is good
because we have learned that she comes
into Avengers in game pretty early on in
the film in this photo right here we
know in this scene
Captain America still has his beard but
he's clean-shaven in the trailer and in
the TV spot and based off of what Kevin
Feige has told us we know that the
footage from the trailer and the TV spot
should take place within the first 15 to
20 minutes of the movie
so therefore Captain Marvel arrives
pretty early it'll be interesting to see
a new more developed Captain Marvel
alongside with the Avengers and Avengers
in game which is something that we get
to see pretty soon so let me know what
you think about her new outfit and let
me know how you think she's going to
interact with the Avengers and Avengers
end game let me know in the comments
down below and a quick reminder about my
giveaway I'm giving away five imax
tickets if you'd like to enter for your
chance to win all you have to do is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero or
villain as always thank you all so much
for watching
woof woof
[Music]